欢迎回来听类型（type）与类（class）的第二讲
既然学的是函数式编程 这次讲的是函数的类型
函数 值 和类型十分重要 因为对初学者有些困难
这节课请特别注意 因为一旦错过 之后会遇到很多困难
我会慢慢讲 重复几次 因为理解这一部分十分重要
什么是函数
函数将一个类型的值映射成另一个类型的值
这是两个函数类型的简单例子
第一个是函数 not （逻辑非）接收一个布尔值
返回另一个布尔值
没什么复杂的
看第二个函数 isDigit （是否为数字）
isDigit 接收一个字符 检查是否是数字 从 0 1 2 到 9
类型是 Char （字符）到 Bool （布尔值）
含义是它从所有字符的集合中接受一个值 返回所有布尔值集合中的一个值
一般而言 从 t1 到 t2 的函数类型是 t1 -> t2
意味着它将 t1 类型的值映射到 t2 类型的值
t1 有时被叫做函数的定义域（domain）t2 叫做值域（range）
注意函数类型中的箭头 用了美观的箭头
但用键盘敲代码时
应该输入短横线（dash, -）接着一个大于号（>）
这里用漂亮的记号 但输入时不是打出一个真的箭头
定义函数时 和元组与列表一样 定义域和值域的类型不受限制
比如函数 add （求和）接收两个整数（Int）的元组作为参数 返回一个整数
add (x, y) 等于 x 加 y
注意 add 的类型 接收两个整数的元组 返回一个整数
另一个函数接收一个整数 返回一个整数的列表
完全可以这样
定义是 zeroto n （0 到 n）返回列表 [0..n] 第一节课已经见过
方括号和两个点表示从 0 到 n 的列表
注意 如果允许函数的参数与返回值的类型任意取 其类型也可能是函数
因此出现了柯里化函数（curried functions）
不将 add 定义成接受一对整数返回一个整数
Haskell 中更常见的定义是
将 add 定义成接受一个整数 返回另一个函数 它接收一个整数并最终返回一个整数
请看类型 add 是一个函数
箭头告诉我们它接收一个整数 返回一个函数
这一函数接受另一个整数 最终返回一个整数
这就是柯里化
柯里化本身并不复杂 函数和列表 整数一样 只是值 没什么特殊的
让人困惑的是 在 Haskell 中不需要在这里写括号（原文误作箭头）
因为太过常用 箭头自动向右结合
也就意味着可以把类型写成
Int -> Int -> Int 常常令初学者感到困惑
你需要学会阅读这些类型时 知道在哪里加括号
没什么特殊的地方
add 是一个函数 接收一个整数 返回一个函数
该函数接收一个整数 返回一个整数
注意 add 和 add' 返回相同的结果
但通常的 add 接收一个元组 因此同时接收两个参数
而 add' 依次接收参数
依次接收参数的函数称为 柯里化函数
发明这种依次接收参数的函数处理方式的人是哈斯凯尔·B·柯里（Haskell B. Curry）
Haskell 就是以他命名的 正如 Pascal 语言是以布莱兹·帕斯卡（Blaise Pascal）命名的
Haskell 是为了纪念哈斯凯尔·B·柯里命名的
也就是发明了函数柯里化的人
任何一个接收两个参数的函数都可以转换成依次接收参数的函数
比如这个函数 mult 接收三个参数 x y z 并将其相乘
mult x y z 等于 x 乘 y 乘 z
一种定义方式是接收三个值的元组并将其相乘
更 Haskell 的方式是依次接收三个参数
mult x 返回一个函数
该函数接收另一个参数 y
再返回一个函数 接收另一个参数 z
但三个参数都有时 就可以将其相乘
返回最终的整数
mult 接收一个整数
返回函数 mult x 接收另一个整数 y
再返回一个函数 mult x y 接收一个整数 z
返回结果 x 乘 y 乘 z
可以看到函数的类型中仍然写了括号 从左向右
而函数的箭头向右结合
当我们写 mult x y 时 不用加括号
假如添加回括号的话 将是
(mult x) 外面再加括号
这类括号向左结合 也就是应用函数向左结合 函数箭头向右结合 二者是完美的结合
因此实践中不需要写括号
现在可能要问 柯里化有什么用呢
为什么不像其他语言中 让函数接收整个参数列表
或者用元组精确指定参数呢
为什么要做如此复杂的事情 接收一个参数返回另一个函数等等
原因是 这样可以部分应用一个函数（partially apply 又译局部调用）
例如这个函数 add'
使用柯里化的方式定义 就可以定义一个函数 将值增加 1 方法是将 add' 部分应用到 1 上
add' 1 的类型是一个函数 接收一个整数 返回另一个整数
将来讲列表时 可以看到很多将一个列表转化为其他列表的函数
大多数都是用柯里化的方法定义的
例如这里的 take 函数 部分应用成 take 5
take 被定义为一个柯里化函数 接收一个整数 返回一个从列表到列表的函数
意味着可以将 take 部分应用到 5 上 得到一个函数 可以将一个整数列表转换为另一个
由输入列表前五个元素组成的列表
类似的 drop 函数
接收一个整数 返回一个从列表到列表的函数
现在可以定义 drop 5
也就是部分应用 drop 到 5 上 返回一个函数
接收一个列表作为输入 丢弃前五个元素 返回剩下的列表 太方便了
这种用法在 Haskell 中十分轻量 Haskell 的语法针对柯里化进行了优化
在这方面 Haskell 与大多数优化接收元组作为参数的函数的语言不同
我已经讲过了几次 书写函数参数括号的方式
箭头向右结合 比如下面的类型 Int -> (Int -> (Int -> Int))
括号向右结合 由于我们不想写括号
因此可以写成 Int -> Int -> Int -> Int.
如果把省略的括号加回去 就是底下的表达式 但实际写的是上面这种
因为不想写不必要的括号
另外 当函数应用时 括号向左结合
部分应用一个函数时 可以写括号
但没必要 写出 mult x y z
意思是 (((mult x) y) z)
除非你显式使用元组 Haskell 中通常所有函数都是用柯里化的方式定义的
而多数编程语言中 所有的函数都是非柯里化的方式定义的
这就是关于函数的第二部分 会有很多练习考虑函数类型中 哪里应该加括号
表达式中 哪里应该加括号
它很快就会成为第二天性 一直做下去就会连想都不用想
好的 请完成练习 第二章的最后一个部分再见